in your case Mr vadasia the significant
aggravating feature of planning
concealment and the location of the
offense
are balanced out to some extent by your
good character and the other mitigating
features mentioned
I consider that the minimum term
should therefore be 18 years
that is the minimum term in your case
in your case Mr shargo the additional
mitigating feature of the lack of an
intention to kill and the other
mitigating features including your good
character mean that the minimum term
should be reduced by one year
the appropriate minimum term in your
case is therefore 16 years
ideal now very briefly with the sentence
for the possession of a bladed article
having regard to the relevant guidelines
the appropriate categorization of these
offenses is category 1A the starting
point for which is 18 months with a
range of one to two years detention
after trial
that starting point and range is for
adult Defenders over the age of 18 and
an adjustment must be made to take
account of your age
the aggravating features of planning and
concealing your identity are balanced
out by your absence of convictions
adjusting the starting point for age
that leads me to a term of 12 months
credit for your plea reduces this
further to eight months accordingly the
sentence in each of your cases for
counts two and three is eight months
which will run concurrently
will the defendants please stand
tragic verdesa for the murder of Ronan
Kanda I sentenced you to detention for
life at his Majesty's pleasure with a
minimum term of 18 years
for the possession of a bleeded article
are sentenced due to eight months
detention to run concurrently
from the minimum term of 18 years they
must be deducted
the 375 days you have spent on remand
and custody for this offense
the minimum term is accordingly 18 years
less the 375 days
Superman charcoal
for the murder of Ronan Kanda are
sentenced you to detention for life at
his Majesty's pleasure with a minimum
term of 16 years
for the possession of depleted article I
sentence you also to eight months
detention to run concurrently
from the minimum term of 16 years must
be deducted the 375 days you have spent
on demand and custody for this offense
the minimum term
accordingly is 16 years less 375 days
the victim surcharge missiles to be paid
in both cases
it's important to emphasize so that you
and all those who are listening and
viewing this sentence
can understand the position the minimum
term is just that
a minimum period which cannot be reduced
in any way
after your respective minimum terms are
served there is no guarantee that you
will be released at that time or at any
particular time thereafter
it is only if the parole board decides
that you're no longer a danger to
society
fit to be released that you will you
will be released
that will not be before you have served
every day of your minimum term
even if you are released after serving
your minimum term
you will remain subject to license for
the rest of your life
that means you may be recalled to
continue your life sentence at any time
if considered appropriate
it is in these ways that a life sentence
with a minimum term protects the public
for the future
that concludes my sentence